okay everybody I am absolutely thrilled
today because I am joined by Lady Beau
Katan herself Katie Sackhoff we're
talking all things Mandalorian season
three and a little bit of Clone Wars
those will be spoilers for both so make
sure you finish those first before you
watch this Katie how you doing today I'm
good how are you I'm doing great I
absolutely love the finale in this whole
season of Mandalorian so I'm really
excited to talk with you about this
especially because it's a really big
season for Beau but before we get into
that just talking about Mandalorian
season two and your character being
introduced to live action which was
really really cool uh it really broke
ground did you realize would have this
big impact because you see now that
thrawn's gonna be the live action
version same actor and you being the
same actress did you realize that and
were you ever worried it wasn't going to
work at all
um you know I I think that it's really
really important to always cast the
right person for the role you know
um and in my situation it worked uh to
my benefit
um which is great
um you know but like I've said multiple
times it's not like I was off doing you
know romantic comedies in a corset for
the last 20 years like you know
characters like Beau are are in my
wheelhouse it's sort of what I've made a
career out of so
um so I'm I'm glad that I got the
opportunity I don't know if they thought
of anybody else for it but they could
have I'm sure they did
um but I think that you know like you
know I just think that the right person
should get the role I'm super excited
for thrawn to be
um in live action it's such a cool
character
um and I just can't wait to see what
color of blue he is no for sure and it's
cool though but that's true but true
though because you like you know pave
the way for that and broke ground which
is really cool and I think people got
more excited too because that connection
to Boca time that you would have from
the animated series and speaking of that
though I want to talk about just I
always think about this with Boca tan
but her first appearance ever in Clone
Wars back in 2012. I I love that she
gives Ahsoka like this baseball coach
slap on the butt is if you guys ever
cross paths in live action can you
promise us right now that they'll
reference this somewhere in the show can
you fight for that you know it's funny
it's uh it's one of those things that
you know you can't always portray
characters that are morally perfect you
know they live in the this gray world
would I slap another woman on the butt
probably not
um you know but maybe I would if she was
a really good friend I might I don't
know it depends
um I don't know I'm sure I'm sure it
will be referenced I'm sure people want
to reference it it'd be kind of cheeky
if it was but at the same time you know
uh I think they've both grown as people
yeah at least bojas no
it's crazy too with the whole lore of
Beau and her huge story we've already
seen in different timelines but what
really sticks out to me too about with
Clone Wars with Bo is that this trauma
she sees watching Darth Maul execute
previousla but also just losing her
sister to Darth Maul so when you go back
and do the live action of her for
Mandalorian do you ever watch The
Animated work to like tap back into some
of her character or do you kind of just
leave that aside now well I I mean I
haven't
um I definitely we did before
Mandalorian just to make sure that I
remembered everything that we had done
um but I think that
um you know that emotional complexity of
that character those those losses
absolutely
um plays into who she is now and and
those things are definitely things that
I thought of especially this season the
entire time that we were filming you
know the loss of Satine is is such a
huge part of her life part of her
trajectory I think the moment she lost
her sister
it changed
her direction for forever
um and
um and so that would be terribly
terribly misguided if I if I didn't do
that yeah no but it's interesting too
and I'm happy to hear that you do do
that but also that speaking of sateen I
do you ever just as a fan and the nerd
side of you watching this think of a
universe where she is Obi-Wan's
brother-in-law Bo is that is that
something you've ever thought of have
you ever kind of just pondered on that
I've definitely like you know questions
who Bo knows you know like who does Bo
know in this world you know what does
Obi-Wan mean to her
what has happened to them in the past
um who is he to her now all of those
questions go go through my mind
um and you know I um I don't know it's
it's I'm sure Dave has all the answers
to all of this stuff like that's the
cool thing about felony is that he
already has all the answers to all of
this stuff it's just a matter of whether
or not I get to be privy to it or not
yeah yeah absolutely you know I wish
that we could talk about sateen you know
I think Kate Blanchett would be amazing
[Laughter]
I love that yeah that I love that
casting Choice that's great
um is there anything though you miss
about doing animated bow compared to
just a live action version is there
something you kind of like Miss about
that specific gig yeah I mean there's a
freedom to just voice in a character you
get to go to work and really just focus
on what it is you're trying to convey
with your voice and the rest of the work
falls on everyone else
you know
um for me
um bow is it's a little outside of my my
acting style you know my acting style is
very um visual I you you know the
characters that I play wear their hearts
on their sleeves and it's you can see
that at all times
so for Bo there is like this Stillness
to her her body and her face that is
um that is challenging for me that I
that that and I love the challenge to to
be able to do something that I haven't
done before
um and uh uh so it's it's easier for
sure and I miss that yeah no for sure
but it's cool because you step up to the
challenge and own it also in two
versions with live action as well and
speaking of live action both so I love
with Mandalorian season three when we
first see her she's chilling on this
throne in this Mandalorian Castle now
the pose she was in was that a Katie
Sackhoff choice or was that the director
or even writer
um so that was the decision of of John
and Rick and myself
um and we sat there and we thought about
it you know I I went in John had me go
in and sit on the throne with my you
know first I went it went in in just my
playing clothes and realized that that
it wouldn't be an accurate assessment
because I I wasn't I wasn't in my armor
I wasn't in my jet pack you know what
does it look like with all that stuff on
so I ran over when they were building
the the throne and sat on it in my
wardrobe and tried to figure out how I
would sit and and then ultimately on the
day it shows up and it's like massive
it's huge and like I I am not that big
I'm five six so I think that you know
you're there's a physical limitation to
the fact that like you can't just sit on
something I would have I looked so dinky
like on this Throne that was one of them
but also you're trying to convey
something right and you want it to not
just be bo sitting on a throne by
herself
you know we wanted it to be
disrespectful we wanted it to be beaten
down we wanted her to look completely
broken
um and you know the best way to do that
is to to figure out how she's gonna sit
so that was that was us sitting in many
many different poses trying to figure
out what worked the best and of course I
had to strike the most uncomfortable one
just
no but it works and it visually sticks
with me that imagery so really cool and
it's a great entrance and what I love
about this season too is that we get to
see Bo a lot with grogu even to grogu
guiding bow to where Mando needs to be
rescued and we also seize the co-pilot a
lot of Bo
um what was it like for you really
having a lot of screen time with your
scene partner being you know a puppet
animatronic was that just a wild
experience
um you know I I I like to say that I can
after doing so much sci-fi in my life
that I can act with a tennis ball
um you know I've had I've had I feel
like in my years I think I've had actors
disappear and I've had to act with
tennis balls
um out of necessity as well so you know
um working with grogu though is more
like working with like a child or an
animal because the puppeteers are are
listening to the scene and they're
controlling the animatronics the entire
time
um so I'm having like
realistic
reactions to Kim because he's
legitimately in the scene with me
um and that's super fun it's just super
fun like I love of working with the the
puppeteers on this in this series of
show are just absolutely amazing and and
um they're just awesome yeah no and it
looks great and it comes off great and
there is that that chemistry that clicks
with the two of those characters which I
really like to see I also I'm curious
just for my fans listening to this
because you probably answer this 100
times but for the dialogue scenes with
the helmet on for Bo are you always
physically in the suit during those
so for the dialogue scenes
um I would say 98 of the time it's me uh
awesome and if it's not me it's uh
purely because I was on there were two
scenes filming in one day on two
different lots and the scene with the
the the most
um the most emotional context needed uh
was the scene that they would throw me
in that day
um but it was it was important to me to
to be there
um you know I would have loved to have
done every stunt possible as well
um contractually I'm not allowed to do
that
I think they're more worried that I'm
gonna get hurt
um than I am sadly
um but I also like you know I say all
the time that this show myself included
Mando included these are two characters
that cannot be portrayed by one person
you know it would do a disservice to the
character and to the audience for me to
egotistically on some days say I'm gonna
do this because I'm not the best person
for the job I had three amazing stunt
women in my suit this year Joanna being
the main one that was in my suit at all
times
she's such a phenomenal athlete she can
do things with her body that that it
would kill me
um and I tried everything once
um because it especially the stuff with
my helmet off you have to do it the
helmet's off there's you have to do as
much of it as you can
um but there will be days where
um I am smart enough to know my own
limitations uh where I just pull myself
out of it and say I'm going to watch the
professional do it do what she does no I
love to hear that and I love that you
give them props and it's very
collaborative that's very cool of you
and I lost two speaking of that you
posted on your Instagram a couple days
ago you had the knee guards on and the
knee slides so was that a situation like
what was kind of going on there dude are
there people that sit there scared of
you getting hurt like is it like Katie
don't put those on is that a thing yeah
100 that's the thing that's holding me
back
it's not me you know I mean it's funny
too because you know I had just left a
show before this
before Mandalorian where I did all my
own stunts like that's what I was known
for I I do my Falls I do my fights I do
all of that stuff
you know partially out of necessity when
I started in this industry I was bigger
than most of the women and we couldn't
find scent doubles that matched my body
size
so I mean I I've been doubled by a man
before
um because they couldn't find a woman
that matched me that was 25 years ago
this industry has changed so much and
there are so many phenomenal stunt
performers
um uh is and and female and male stunt
performers that are just absolutely
phenomenal that you would you would not
run into that same problem today
absolutely not
um uh but yeah no it is it is not it is
it is not me stopping myself trust me
there's a moment but uh you know I
remember doing a fall in season two and
having the producer come up to me and he
wanted a verbal
a verbal
like indication that I I didn't feel
pressured to do this fall wow like no no
I'm good man I'm good yeah they were
like are you sure you don't feel PR I
was like dude
now you're making me second-guess myself
holy crap yeah yeah no it's it's uh I
love this stuff the one thing I will
never be able to do on this show though
is wire work that's the thing that
they're just like
okay it won't happen but on my last show
I did it all the time so yeah it's just
you never know right that's cool and I I
love you post that picture too because I
think Star Wars fans love to see that
you're having fun too because it's like
you're a kid on the set that's that's
what we want for Star Wars that's
awesome
um
yeah and uh I won't talk about this big
moment too in the season where Bo sees
the mythosaur
um what do you think because people are
debating this on the Reddit what do you
think her logic was when she came out of
the water and asking Dan about it but
not telling him she saw them at the
store what was her mindset there well
this is a person who did not take the
Legends literally took them
metaphorically you know I don't I I she
came out of that water
you know
seeing the symbol of her people that she
didn't ever dream existed I think she
thinks she's crazy I think she thinks
that she lost oxygen long enough or
something I don't know I think she's
probably thinking what the hell just
what did I see
you know it was also under a stressful
situation
you know she could have imagined that
and I don't think that in this moment
she trusts Mando enough to emotionally
let her guard down
okay no that's a great answer and I
think that makes complete sense and I
wonder too because I think possibly not
my favorite but up there favorite bow
moment was when she got the mythosaur
symbol put on her by the armorer is that
her big moment of now starting to
convert to becoming like a believer of
these things she used to call children's
stories or is she still you know not
fully there yet
I don't know I don't know
I think that boat is changing she's
evolving
she's becoming a different person
she's she's becoming a more faithful
person
but I think uh I think right now her
faith lies in people and in her people
and and that's sort of this that where
she's headed yeah no for sure and I
think it made her character really
interesting this season too and I love
it just it follows her Arc perfectly
from Clone Wars to now which is really
cool I also love this moment with Beau
where when she I don't love seeing her
home destroyed but when she sees her
home destroyed she says those mud
scuffers bound my home do you drop a mud
scuffer time to time in your daily life
and is there a list you pick out of
these these Star Wars like curse words
you know it's so funny I uh there have
been some lines in my career that I am
just like what am I saying
um you know and but you gotta convey you
gotta make sure that you say that line
with conviction
um but I have you know over the years in
my sci-fi I don't say mud stuffer you
know I also don't say frat people ask me
if I say Frack all the time
um and I don't but uh uh there's some
doozies there's some doozies in there
that John likes to throw in for fun no
yeah and I like it's used like very
little so it's always magic when it
happens that was a great moment and
totally justified her saying that there
I love Beau also that she got the dark
saber the right way this time by
rescuing Mando and how that was kind of
revealed later on and you maybe as an
audience member don't even realize that
that happened which is so cool
um but do you think like with the dark
saber because we see in season two she's
like really on a mission to get it is is
it bringing her more joy or suffering in
her life would you say if you're
observing that
so I think that Bo
and and for people
and the Mandalorian people have been so
fixated on for lack of a better word to
trinket
um that they've lost sight of she's lost
sight of what really matters to her
people and for her people
so I think she's distracted by it
because I think that
the Mandalorian people were distracted
by it
um and so I I think that uh you know
sadly the destruction of it will will
potentially put things right I guess if
you will okay so that's the big thing
because that's the big controversial
thing right then the season the dark
saber gets destroyed
is that something that was always the
plan this season did you guys film a
version where it didn't get destroyed in
that fight was that always going to
happen it was always the plan it was in
the script
so we knew it was happening and I think
I was a little like I'm sorry you're
doing what
um but it's one of those things right
where I think in order for for Beau and
the mandalorians to have a fresh start
the Right leader has to
do to be leading no matter what they
possess
you know what I mean like I think that
that's one of the things that she learns
in episode six
she sees Jack Black's character get
elected hmm
that's an interesting concept to her
it's like oh
it may not just be I may be a royal
but maybe maybe that's something we need
to do like am I leading because I'm
qualified and my people want me to or am
I leading just because
I think I should and it's in my lineage
and those are questions I think that are
sort of getting answered
absolutely and even just the influence
she has on grogu I really like two in
the season so something gotta go past a
lot of people's heads here is that when
grogu
um interrupts the two tribes fighting
that Mando says he didn't learn that for
me so I implied he learned that from Bo
do you see Bo as sort of a motherly
figure for grogu in a sense in this
season that that's kind of how you read
that
um I mean I saw her as like a motherly
figure for him I think just because
she's there and she's protective over
him
um
I I also think that Bo knows how
important grogu is
you know she knows Jedi she says to him
I fought with Jedi I've been around Jedi
she is she knows she has seen some you
know
a character or a person uh who looks
like grogu
she knows he's important
um because she also knows that that a
lot of the Jedi are in hiding so I think
that that
um she's just incredibly protective over
him whether that be is you know a mother
or a protector or
you know yeah and she does a great job
protecting this season she saves him
Mando it's great she takes a lot of
people's lives throughout her whole
story which is awesome she needs more
credit for that
um I love the moment too when Mando says
to Bo your song is not yet written I
will serve you till it is are those the
type of lines as an actress that really
excite you like yes more job security
when you see a line like that does that
get you like pumped up I mean it is it's
much better than like goodbye I'll see
you on the other side no of course
that's much it's much better to to be
alive at the end of something than
especially if you're like I want to come
back yeah no for sure
um I also just wondered too I think the
big moment of finale everyone really
loved was seeing you and the armor side
by side and you got the dark saber in
your hand are you geeking out just for
your character just as much as we're as
a fan seeing moments like this and did
you have a fun time just bonding with
Emily swallow this season just how great
that relationship was yeah I loved it I
mean Emily and I like we both like text
each other and we were like yeah that's
an awesome moment at the very end you
see them flying next to each other and I
was like hurray let's go and she was
like I got my my Hammers and stuff
um you know I'm I'm so funny what I'm
talking about and I'm like she's got her
Hammers and I've got a sword like let's
go
um it was awesome like Emily and I had
such a good time together you know we're
both such dorks that uh that you know
she and I you put us in a in a room with
nothing on the walls and and nothing to
entertain ourselves and and we'll have
written an entire musical by the time
you come back
um
I love that yeah and it's cool to see
you two be your last shot of the season
with her it makes me excited for the
future and seeing Bo now having
Mandalore again and rolling all these
two tribes now bringing these people
together so what do you hope to see what
is your dream to see for maybe Bo in the
future of Star Wars like anything you
dream of seeing
oh gosh there's so much about Beau that
that I'd love to see you know she's got
some backstory still that would be
really interesting to dive into and
actually see in live action
um I don't know what the the future and
and her story holds for her we'll just I
guess have to wait and see
I want to ask you too have you ever
thought about directing an episode ever
of the Mandalorian or any of the Star
Wars shows
you know it's funny I was talking about
this with the the last interviewer that
I that I talked to and I never really
thought about it
you know I think that I always joke that
that I only have enough bandwidth for
one egotistical actor and it's me
um
no it's actors are the actors are hard
man they you know you got to deal with a
lot of moving parts and egos at work and
it's like hurting cats sometimes but um
I uh I think the most important thing
with being a director is just knowing
how to to put the camera where the story
is and and knowing what the story is in
order to be able to do that to
facilitate the the emotion that you want
the audience to to sort of feel
I never really thought about it until I
started talking about that
I you know I can I can absolutely
pinpoint what bad directing is
okay I don't know if I can figure out
what good directing is what it what that
looks like you know I I know when I've
worked with great directors but I don't
know if I can do what they do
so we'll just have to say I've got no
idea I've got no idea I think it could I
think the fans would love to see it so
I'll be dreaming for that
um you're always so great to fans too
and this is a huge fan base with Star
Wars
um for something like this is that just
as important as the work to you is like
being kind to these fans and
understanding like how emotionally
invested they are in this
a hundred percent you know I mean
I've been doing this now for over 25
years I have a career I have a large
portion of my career that I owe to the
fans and for for coming along with me
and and following me from job to job
watching movies that I feel like I
should pay them back for
um you know because there's so much
support from them
um and so it's just a matter of respect
right
um and so I I love to talk to the fans
and meet the fans and
um this is an interesting World though
right because you're never going to make
everyone happy
um and Star Wars fans are really vocal
and sometimes it's it's hard to hear to
read criticisms
especially when I think they're
unfounded
but art is subjective and everybody's
allowed to to take you know to have
their own opinion they can hate you if
they want
um you know they can hate my work
um just don't come after my family yeah
right yeah hell yeah
no yeah I mean if you hate Bo you hate
Beau that's totally fine that's a good
mindset to have I like that
um and yeah and speaking of family
you're just making me think about this
great moment too because there's so many
great moments of this season but with
grogu having the fire away from Beau and
Mando and a lot of people you see on
Twitter will say like this is my Star
Wars family now they're a family I love
that and I think it comes in Full Circle
and pays off and that was developed
really well the whole season but to
other people do you see any chance of
like Chemistry Between Mando and Vogue
could you see that over them linking up
I know I love the shipping it's
hysterical they're like bow and the
armor there should be oh Dan like you
know it was definitely talked about this
season Brendan and I joked about it all
the time trying to figure out how that
would work I don't even know how that
would work
I joked with my friend Christian harloff
over on his podcast
that you know that they would just have
to you know be post coital as close to
the The Living Waters as possible just
to roll back in and get redeemed all
over
that we gotta keep it PG right you know
yeah that's the beautiful thing about
this show is that you can sit down and
you can watch it with your your
little five-year-old and also you know
my my parents and everybody likes it for
different reasons and they like it for a
lot of the same reasons
um so we got to maintain that but you
never know that's awesome I know I love
that answer it's a fair answer and um
yeah I'm excited to see all these great
leaderships Beau is in and what might
happen with her with that and Before I
Let You Go Katie my last question for
you is not your favorite Star Wars
character of all time but it's just in
your head recently is there a character
really vibing with installers you're
really like I'm into that character
right now and the whole lore of things
oh my God I mean I've always loved
Ahsoka yeah I love soca
I love that I can't wait to see the show
I love Dave filoni's directing style I
love that he has the confidence as a
director
to to to Pace things slow and to to show
you a big long wide
he's really interesting to watch
um so I don't know I I think that it
would probably be I think it'd be
probably her just purely because I I
want to see it you know yeah hell yeah
it's a great answer and I yeah she's
amazing
um so thank you so much Kate for joining
me everybody watched the Mandalorian
Clone Wars Rebels they all have Bo in it
on Disney plus check out Battlestar
collect if you haven't seen it also
worth your time she also's YouTube
channel and she's a great Tick Tock
that's really funny so Katie thank you
so much for joining me I hope to talk to
you in the future one day thank you have
a good one